[Music]
yo
hey we're doing it we might be drunk
we're back we're here still hungover
different day
it's a problem but hey what's more
appropriate to being hungover on an
alcohol show
thinking i hung over last time i saw you
i was
way worse i was like handicapped
hungover dana hashem everybody let her
hear it
you guys can clap or something mark says
that all right
is there something i should be looking
for no it doesn't matter okay look off
into the distance
thanks for joining us dina we got a
little natty wine we want to use the
globe
yeah
i love a globe i just found some natty
wine
nice looks good hell yeah is that
pharrell on the on the bottle there who
is that what's that metal street on
there
love
you could have said quiet mouse i don't
know how you went with gay going for
comedy
gay people are
funny have you seen fire island
i haven't is it good oh it's great
really it's good yeah i heard it's great
it's pride and prejudice right um
pretty much which is also super gay
yes oh you're gonna crack that all right
notice a lot of these wine bottles are
going
unscrew now
so
i like the cork
it's got a core
i think corks are bad for the
environment did you hear that quirks i
don't i don't know give that a goog i
think they're it's like keurig the
keurig pods they're ruining everything
oh for sure i mean well plastic is just
in general yeah going to kill it and
current coffee is dog [ __ ] i'm drinking
one right now
they're [ __ ] horrible yeah but
they're so convenient you gotta admit
they're in every office in the in the
country did i sell you on the grinding
brew though oh i love the grind
send in some more bags of coffee by the
way folks are you a coffee person dina i
have become one my whole life i never
drink coffee and then i had a cup and i
was like oh my whole personality was
defined by not having coffee
it's it's so much better to live this
way but now i'm addicted to it like i
feel tired without it i don't even enjoy
it it doesn't taste good i don't like
the taste of it the first cup when
you're like you ever sick for like 10
days and then you just have one cup of
coffee on day 11 and and the coffee hits
you so hard oh it's the best well you
went you went 11 days without coffee i
when i'm sick i don't drink a ton of it
oh man it's like just part of my it's
like brushing my teeth now i just have a
coffee it's an antidepressant i'm told
too i'm like oh that makes sense it's
not working on me
all right
tell me what you think this could be
weird natural wine is always very funky
no sulfites
a little cloudy okay
yeah it's very thick and and it's more
juicy than actual wine somehow
yeah it looks more like a juice
tell me what you think
that's pungent
my god damn that's strong
tina we can get we have other alcohol
tart it smells it's like sort of nail
polish remover yes getting hints of nail
polish well mark and i like sucking on
fingers
um i think it's kind of i think you got
to give it a minute but this could be
good
oh i like it i'm into it i like it
better than regular you're not into it
dean i'll make you a cocktail we got a
full bar oh my god that'd be really
exciting yeah all right what do you what
do you want do what do we have mad do we
have a ton of [ __ ]
you want to mic me up and i'll go over
there
i haven't seen you that appalled since
you had bacon that one time
well this is my mom's worst nightmare
when i first started doing stand up she
was like i don't want you hanging around
bars and men
[Laughter]
it's beautiful your mom is very
religious yeah i mean she's a different
person now she's like chilled out but
she was a nightmare when i was growing
up oh really
my dad was the same way
not like that well not not he's not a
muscle
but he was just a scary dad and then he
as he got older he just chilled out and
he's an old man now and he's like how
are you they want to keep you in your
life and their life exactly
and they're weak and tired i think also
so they're kind of it's a survival thing
like i gotta be nice this guy can beat
me up now
whereas as a kid it's a hairy knuckled
you know guy and a wife beater
what about was a mama was she a hitter
only once only once when you know
one time and i see it makes me feel bad
to like tell bad stories about it
because she's so nice and gentle now
like i don't want that image oh we don't
have to put it out there
what are we talking curvy sword a wooden
spoon yeah she took a scimitar
is that what those are called uh the
curvy stone yeah a scimitar
no one
what do you like
uh i do tequila usually but i'll have
anything is this tequila
tequila in the top on the right
it's so strong it's heavy duty the
natural wine is no joke
or something what do you like
is that mint in there i'd love something
oh yeah this is our second app
so buckle up sister i love that you just
drink all day for work not bad huh
and then we do stand up we have a drink
there oh yeah i was literally just
talking to a girl she goes i have
interviews all day i'm like i got to
work too
oh yeah
not too shabby
every comic on earth has done the joke
but it's such a great joke you
understand why things become hacky
because they're actually they work
but he you've heard the joke where the
comic goes on stage takes a swig looks
at his notes checks his phone and goes
you're telling me when you get to work
you start right away yeah yeah kills
classic whoever the first person to
think of that was hats off
but i have no idea
it's i've heard it eight thousand times
by nine different people
you were just writing for a show in uh
california how was that i was it was
really fun it was my first time writing
like a joke for something other than
myself and then seeing it be used like
in a script like i'm excited to watch
the show now to see like someone say my
joke and it's very exciting
no it's a sex lives of college girls oh
but were you running for an anime show
oh before i was writing for a for a
muzzy cartoon
wow muzzy cartoon the first of its kind
hey
groundbreaking
what's uh what's what's the parameter is
it about a woman not talking what do we
what's the i wish that's that's
um
no one's interested in showing the
female muslim perspective i have to
complain it's just it's really difficult
that's the one i want to see really well
this struggle is real i mean the the the
the burke uh
berka the burka is part of it yeah yeah
and then the the rocks and the no
driving i think yeah yeah i think well
you know saudi arabia is really playing
they give a lot of money to
american entertainment they have a large
stake in it so this is my conspiracy
theory that they're saying don't don't
give anything to a muslim woman we can't
i see i only like conspiracy theories
that um protect me from feeling failure
do you ever get nervous about the
backlash
um well i i mean i'm sort of
desensitized to it after a certain the
was i was over there what with the
backlash and what like a muslim backlash
i mean yeah no i think one day if i were
to get some sort of like
large special or something like that it
could be it could be an issue but that's
exciting like you know i guess you've
dealt with it already you ready like i
feel like the worst that could happen
you already got hit with and we don't
have to talk about this video i don't
care um well the thing is i think
muslims would actually carry out their
threats of violence exactly
[Laughter]
that's an example
but you said in a funny way
usually 9 11.
that's why we're laughing it was
[Laughter]
what uh yeah yeah i could but you dealt
with it in a way that was so unfair
we're like i thought your joke was funny
great joke you posted a joke about this
rapper not even me comedy central they
posted it yeah good point but
what we do as comics is we write topical
jokes i didn't think your joke was
mocking a dead person first off i i
think comics kind of have free reign to
begin with but
you made a joke that was like it's the
perfect ad for venmo because you got
killed with a lot of money right yeah
basically that's a funny turn and it's
not against him no in the joke i say
it's tragic that he died so i
exactly they see blood young people on
the internet see blood and they're like
it's a way it's sick well it's just that
fan base is i mean the guy who just got
um who did
what was the last mass shooting i lose
track what was the last one oh the park
i mean this is coming out in three weeks
so it'll be about five or ten more
the chicago yes so the guy who did that
was like one of those guys he was an emo
rap guy with like the face tattoos like
he probably sent me a death threat
during that time probably that's why i
was so scared
it could only take one weirdo to like
see your address and actually want to do
something to you that's true that's true
yeah and that guy it's like really the
the classy well-read murderers are a
thing of a past yeah like the ones who
like quote shakespeare and like like we
thought we were talking about john
wilkes move before like you like shouted
out something from julius caesar right
sirens yeah now now it's like when
someone murders someone they're like it
was something from uh i don't [ __ ] do
you got a soundcloud yeah yeah limewire
or something i don't know right my face
tattoo
i mean this dude was a [ __ ] i mean
losers understatement but my my
girlfriend tweeted something about r
kelly like hey i'm glad he's in jail and
she got a ton of [ __ ] like yeah and
you're like usually with him you get
pissed
clip it
what is uh what is going on here like
you can't be mad at the guy who kept
women in a dungeon and pissed on him and
all that like
what are we doing here you really want
to be on that side of it in this twitter
fight
it's weird yeah it is weird i mean but
you know what all it takes is those die
hard fans and those people like
they have fans man oh yeah would it be
nice to have a fan base like that that
would like kill for you sure
hell yeah
yeah but it's dangerous look any mumble
rapper if there's one less i'm happy i'm
all for it it's a shitty art or whatever
you want to call it it's a bad genre
it's got mumble in it it sucks how do
you sell a dude that looks like that a
gun too like he that look is [ __ ]
if i saw a dude like that i'm like you
just i was on a bus i went away out of
the city for a few days and i was on a
bus and there were two dudes that looked
like that and i was like i'm [ __ ]
dead
you just think you're you just visualize
they're gonna just kill everyone on the
bus yeah it's becoming more mainstream
now it's actually gone into basic [ __ ]
culture like now you can find like white
blonde girls with face tattoos it's
becoming a thing i got a message from a
fan and she was like i got this face
tattoo and i and i wrote back like a
joke
because i have this like app community
where you can text
you know you know that i don't know this
well they can text you it's like tech
you know when people say in their
instagram profile you can text me here
yeah it goes to this it's not like my
real number obviously crazy but it's
like
the thing you can blast it tells you the
city they're in so you can blast the
city when you come
so this woman texts me and sometimes i
respond she goes i got this horrible
face that too and i wrote a joke back
and she goes no i'm serious and she
sends a picture and she goes it's it's
like a wiccan tattoo that's been
appropriated by nazis
i'm like i mean yeah i mean you lost me
at face tattoo it's already a bad idea
but you picked one that got that's like
a nazi uh you have a nazi face tattoo
well appropriated
by nazis that's a funny reason to be mad
at nazis
they stole my idea
it's like a picture where you're like
almost like i made a joke i thought she
was kidding like it sounds like
something is like a joke yeah yeah but
it is getting more normalized for sure
you see a guy with a face tattoo and it
was like a teardrop thing he was in jail
he killed a guy whatever but now it's
like a post malone
there's more job opportunities that's
what it comes down to you you used to be
you used to get like a neck tattoo and
it's like you can't get a job yeah i
remember that old todd berry joke so i
got a neck tattoo the other day and you
think man you forgot to not do that
great joke it's so simple
yeah the face tattoo i mean
it has to be that way i mean you have to
keep
ramping up but now how do you how do you
prove now that you're really a freak
there's like no way to do it like you
have to be normal in order to be
counter culture
tip to be square
i think you're right that's punk khakis
are pumpkins yes
dockers whoa easy there
dude the stainless dockers those
those are made for alcoholics yeah
those are made for drunks where you're
like you literally can spell nothing
yeah that's a g old pan should be
stainless you know who would be a great
uh spokesperson for that as monica
lewinsky
like i would should have been wearing
these you know they're gonna say burke
crusher oh oh wow that's a different
stain
but yeah but you uh so you're working on
these shows and you're in a writer's
room and this new one it's mindy kalin
right yeah and how what season is it
second season i wasn't on the first
season just
and it's like younger it's younger
characters right yeah they're all in in
college um and they're just uh you know
[ __ ] doing a lot of [ __ ]
um
i have no experience like i could i
cannot bring any personal experience to
the show because i was still like a
recovering muslim in college it's just
funny that i'm not that
[Laughter]
but uh
i mean it's great you're getting
experience in these rooms now because i
we needed dina
yes
i've got it i've got so many ready to go
and people are excited in a meeting and
then i imagine they get a call from like
the royal family in saudi
i don't arabia
yeah i don't know t that tv world the
meetings are so fun they're the worst
we're huge fans well you own a network
yes you can make it happen
we look if it was our choice you're
netflix it is your choice yeah it's like
when biden tweets like oh this is
terrible it's like yeah you can do
something
all right i think the brittany grinder
[ __ ] just to me i'm like how are you not
doing something about that
[ __ ] prison i think trump got like
asap rocky yeah but that was like sweden
or something
yeah russia's a different animal like
i'll give you that yeah
but also like dude
she's like it's like 100 days i mean
more when this comes out hopefully she's
out but i mean that's like and it was
that breaks you it was cbd oil it was
like the least uh harmful or hash oil
okay that's something you want to be the
person that corrects the guy there it
was actually it was hash which is yeah
i didn't know about it but they're
athletes they got joint issues exactly
it's helpful it's it's medicinal
lebron got a ton of [ __ ] because he said
something like if i that was me i
wouldn't even i don't even know if i'd
want to come back to america because
they're not fighting but then he was
saying like no i love america i'm just
saying
i'm just saying that i would feel hurt
that they're not trying to fight to get
me back well we need you to tweet about
it
apparently that makes waves
but yeah that i mean that's one come on
that's one call
that's all yeah but they probably russia
probably wants us to trade like a
terrorist form uh yeah that's probably
the move they're like we'll give you
this uh innocent mw-nba player but you
gotta give us a guy who slits someone's
throat give him
yeah
i don't know
you don't peters okay okay he's he was
big he was huge he's still in l.a i
think oh yeah nice guy nice guy you met
him i've met him i met up at the store
once sweet guy funny guy he's that in
soviet russia yes
soviet russia car drives you or whatever
but it was a hit
it was the uh getter don of it yes
he's the
i'm getting into it i'm sorry you hated
it dana that's all right i mean in my
mind i like organic stuff but this is
not it
it's weird it's vinegary you know what
it's you know what it tastes like the
first time you taste your mom's wine and
you're like
that's what this tastes takes me back
yeah
i like it
what about uh kick
yeah it is tough what the hell are you
thinking what was that orange one you
had last time i like to mix it up why do
we always have to do orange one i wanna
i wanna [ __ ] experience [ __ ] dude and
you're like should peters get it or
should i get them like you get it you'll
get the right one and then you come back
with old
dice they reckon they said this was a
really good one
this is this feels like welch's somebody
[ __ ] in a welches
all right sorry we got a guest here i
[ __ ] up nah you're fine i'm not to be
trusted anymore
it's natural though at least it's
natural
this is uh i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
just always a pilot this is my
relationship dynamic i'm sorry
i [ __ ] up
so wait uh back to the writer's room
because i don't i've only been in like
two writers rooms and it was for award
shows
and uh so that's easy because it's in
and out it shoots once this is a tv show
that has multiple
episodes but uh
would you prefer stand-up or do you like
do you like to mix it up or do both my
ideal world is that i have my own show
and i can like create the room and have
like people like my friends in it that
seems like the most fun thing to me just
having a room of your friends like
coming up with jokes and stuff yeah it's
a little harder with people you don't
know because you don't know if your
sense of humors will like clash or
something like that but i got lucky in
that room everyone was really funny and
cool but were there stand-ups were they
all just pure no stand-ups yeah writer's
rooms are actually great for improv
people it's like the one thing they
really should do and like have the skill
for because you're just sitting in a
room and saying whatever comes to your
head right um
yeah they can they can keep the ball in
the air exactly whereas with stand up
i'm like i want it's my like little dark
art i want to be in a room secluded and
writing things but that's not how it
works exactly and stand-ups are all
about the end of the joke we want the
punch line and that's it and they're
like they can just keep yes ending
volley volley and they find more stuff
yeah they're team players right
stand-ups are selfish as [ __ ]
we're such selfish people i know we're
really brutal it's true i was talking to
my therapist today and i was like i'm
selfish and i was like hoping he would
be like you're not he was like yeah
oh my god good therapist are they
allowed to be honest with you like that
they've never gone into it
the writer's room you know what seems
like a fun writer's room was i watched a
documentary on arrested development and
it's just the funnest
uh it was right before that time where
like things got a little dicey and you
couldn't say this or that and uh they
were they said crazy [ __ ] on arrested
development and the writer's room just
looks so fun and they're all drone that
guy chuck martin who's at the seller
sometimes he's
he was an arrested developer he's funny
he was a producer in there i think it
just seemed like they were friends being
funny and then they made a show around
that that's a dream right like we used
to watch you see those clips of those
like friars club roasts and they're just
buddies [ __ ] on each other as
opposed to now it's like a hired gun
being like hey chevy chase no one likes
you
that'll happen well they both use the
n-word jeffy chase and the friars but
yeah
those roasts did seem fun but who knows
they probably walked off stage and hit a
hit a lady or who knows yeah those are
different types they were i'm not saying
they were model citizens but yeah i just
meant the vibe of like the friendship
cultures yeah it's true
dean is the hiccups
is it the tequila's do you get hiccups
when you drink i i mean you know this i
have them every day anyway but
carbonation definitely triggers it damn
hiccups every day she gets the hiccups a
lot every few hours how do you kill that
it's just a disease i don't know oh is
it a disease i mean i don't know i've
had him every day since i was like 14 so
well like for about a half hour or so
well i get like three and then it's over
and then a few hours later i'll get like
three more it's just that sort of
diaphragm thing i don't know wow that's
a wild ailment the scaring doesn't work
right no
no people try people i know i've tried
we've been in the green room like boo
and she's like stop
don't do that you're like you're off the
show what all right
[Laughter]
what uh
jeez is there a name for that
i don't know i went to a doctor once
when i was young and they were just like
get out of here you know
this is not important who cares not
really yeah he's he's got a cancer
patient
i have hiccups
please every day they're really annoying
i get three of them come on
that's a respirator is it is a drink
okay it's great what was this just
tequila it's just tequila soda we're
just keeping it simple here yes well i
thought we had a more impressive bar
matt we got to get some [ __ ]
hey if you're listening send us some
[ __ ] alcohol to gotham studios so we
don't have to pay for it but right here
we need some jan i mean like you look
you never know when you want to have a
negroni i mean there's like basic
cocktails we got to have we got uh tom
papa coming in next week we need vodka
and gin for martini i mean he's a
martini drinker you got that right
that's a good one we do we just need the
you just need to have a full bar if we
go to the studio you have to get fun
mixers like elderflower is really in
right now what is that i don't know it's
like a it's like an herb isn't it yeah
it's
all
right
one
of
those
elderflower i've never heard of
elderflower in my life
i'm not against an older flower i guess
it is i don't know what it is is that
like a really old virgin i don't know
what that is
but yeah i'm down but yeah it'd be nice
to have a mini fridge with a bunch of
soda water and well we do have
we have it right there we have a mini
fridge what are you talking about well
maybe some like um you know what do you
call it bloody mary mix some limes in
there you know bloody mary's is big for
this because we come in here feeling
like dog [ __ ] a lot
and then we have to work then we just
talk we're doing our job how did so the
first writing uh job was that like did
you submit or was that
you were you brought in or the first one
was just through romney just because
yousef yeah
good dude yeah yeah um yeah he has
that's the muzzy cartoon that's going to
be coming out at some point
and it's also my first voice acting gig
which is something i really just have
always wanted to do you have a great
voice
you do thank you and someone finally
noticed and
i mean some would say it's a game out
but i think it's wonderful i think it's
very nice well actually the role
the role i got is not far from that it's
a suicidal lamb
isn't that me that's me that's you they
nailed it now if it has a hiccup problem
a suicidal lamb that's that sounds like
a hell of a punk band
suicidal voiceover is the the dream gift
i look at hanka's area i'm like that's
like the dream career the best aside
from the documentary made against you by
hari yeah it's a it's a good it's a good
career that's yeah but he also does like
nine voices too yeah like some people
like you're just gonna do your voice not
saying you know
his show brockmire it's a really good
show i gotta get off that it is fun it's
really [ __ ] good yeah it's like
he's just a great actor and he's a
talent i mean birdcage he [ __ ] killed
it and he's in all these great 90s
movies you forget about like heat gross
point blank hank if you're listening i
emailed you and you never responded i'm
serious you never responded to our email
we met once at a dinner it didn't really
work out
uh i think he's scared of comics after
hari
i
you know what happened i was like
william morris our agency set up a
dinner
and it was like just a bunch of people
and i sat down and i didn't plan and i
just sat down next to hanka's area and
i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm sitting next to
hank is there
cool and then i got up to where you know
it was winter i got up to hang up my
jacket as i get up someone sniped and
took my seat
that was a coveted seat i'm on the other
end
i had no wind
damn
come on hank we need you
talk about being a voiceover guy like
it's comics we go oh you're a comedian
tell me a joke he must like come on give
me mo give me pardon oh we would do that
oh my god he's not barney that's dan
castle oh [ __ ] but he does like moe
who does he who does hank's area voice
in the center groundskeeper willie maybe
really i think so
does he do auto
he might do auto yeah
he's also in close point blank which is
one of my favorite 90s comedy great
movies he's in heat he's in a lot of
great movies crazies in heat oh he does
comic book guy
these are some classics and you know
they had another moe but apparently
the guy was a dick and they just got rid
of him oh really
well they nailed it look at appu's last
name is hilarious
oh he does lou and wiggum man kirk van
houten disco stew
disco stew oh god it's impossible to get
these jobs because there's like three
people who can do anything that you want
like john dimaggio and other he does
like bender and like every other oh
that guy's amazing so good remember when
we did that that funeral home in l.a and
mel blanc's tombstone yeah whoa what's
that place called masonic hollywood
forever cemetery yeah well you got that
that cemeteries right there mel blanc
yeah his tombstone just funny that's all
folks oh
how [ __ ] cool oh that's the best but
that guy did every voice ever he was
like a savant that guy yeah next level
yeah so do you you're getting a double
paycheck because you're writing and
voicing
um yeah i wrote on the first season and
now i'm voicing oh that's nice yeah
and that's on amazon it didn't it's
still being like animated and stuff it
takes forever for a cartoon to get made
but i don't know when it'll come out but
when it does i'll be the suicidal lamb
what's the name of the show
i don't think it's been named yet i'm
not sure damn
interesting we'll look out
you'll hear about it i don't even know
if i'm allowed to talk about it
[Laughter]
i hate to break your uh bubble here but
there is a cartoon already called moosie
pull it up it's a french cartoon i had
to watch when i was learning french's oh
muzzy fuzzy oh my god i've been saying
muzzy so often as like a nickname for
muslim and i totally blanked that that's
a word so well i'm just saying that
can't be the name of the new one the new
cartoon
this wine's growing on me yeah it's
getting there
you know what's good this natty wine
gives you no hangover that's true i was
drinking it there it is look at that i
remember the commercials oh yeah that
was big and my school
dude what was the show that uh there was
a show they they used to show at my
school
it was ben affleck was the voyage of the
mimi remember that [ __ ]
no i think it's meme
my dad still says mimi have you seen
this me me but elon musk yeah it's ben
affleck on that [ __ ] what
look at that he's blonde wow too cute
oh kevin's face he's getting hard
somewhere
he looks like the kid in big daddy it's
[ __ ] crazy oh yeah same haircut
oh philip seymour yeah he's classic in
it gwyneth paltrow who plays the british
guy who's really great in it the like
the older guy yeah i don't know
dude lost dad you mean yeah i don't know
but great movie oh and philip seymour
hoffman my favorite actor of all time
[ __ ] i forgot she's in this [ __ ] holy
crap oh baker hall
just passed away rip to a legend james
rebhorn that's who the dad okay yeah
who also passed away recently uh who's
an amazing character actor and isn't
every movie you've ever seen blanchett
psh has such a small role and somehow
steals the whole movie he's yeah such a
creep in it i love it boogie nights he
did the same thing
he always did that he was incredible
incredible i saw he's great magnolia too
but i saw him on uh second avenue once
and it wasn't a pretty sight
he was barreling down second avenue and
everybody's like jumping out of his way
and he he clearly had something
something going on people and [ __ ] has
somehow gotten hotter i don't know
that last movie she's a nightmare alley
not a great movie but she is so hot
that's interesting i mean the word i
would classify her is beautiful
i mean no she's hot really okay go to
the one in the red with the hair uh up
yeah that one
look at those cheekbones baby come on
sit right on my face
i love loving an older woman that's
something i love older women
you know what else is getting hotter and
this is a weird one it's tilda swinton
love similar vibe
similar vibe yeah kind of strange
looking very androgynous i love
androgyny it's my favorite yeah look at
that
she was hot in train wreck
that was not an androgynous role though
very very feminine in that role i love
you know laura dern
in the in a marriage story i think is
that what it's called marriage story
oh you guys it's a great movie
yeah the acting it's so passionate
that's
it's a great movie
oh yeah no bomb back yeah that's a
that's a great movie
yeah great movie i mean talk about just
like raw passion acting it's all script
it's all shockingly good like like i
didn't expect i mean i i'm with norman i
think it's like
it it
delivers a blow especially as someone
who's only dated people on who want to
live in california
it it delivered a real [ __ ] gut punch
to me right yeah i mean r.i.p ray leota
who's grading it yes laura dern is great
and i mean it's a it's a really solid
movie have you ever had a bad breakup
this is gonna hit a nerve okay
yeah she's who else uh hold on i had
another thing oh wait you don't like
adam driver he's the one i never got i
don't get it with him i don't get it
either he's the greatest look at that
face that's the face of the devil people
think he's attractive who gives a [ __ ]
dustin hoffman was a leading man who
does he's cute
hoffman's cute a young hoff like drivers
uh appalling i think talent should trump
everything and i think he's talented is
he that i've actually
i've only seen him in star wars so oh
come on yeah he looks [ __ ] good here
what do we talk what are we doing
facially and he's a marine by the way he
was a marine yeah he's a badass
i think he's a really good actor great
actor
no one denying the acting i'm a fan duh
i'm drinking here come on what are we
doing jesus christ
i'm joking i think he's great i heard
patterson's great too i've never seen it
i heard it's good too i don't know
patterson i like that i feel like that
would be your type of movie it's like a
brooding poet type thing you know yeah
and it's jersey right patterson new
jersey ah
interesting whenever i drive through
there i always think someone should make
a movie by this
town i did the patrice o'neal benefit
and he was in the audience really yeah
that was fun i did that once that was a
i did a really crazy one what does that
mean always the lineup was just oh yeah
yeah but it was it was a great time man
that's a great theater a great
involvement yeah amazing
yeah pretty epic yeah he was there and
uh he came backstage and bill burr was
talking to him oh wow and by the way
he's like 6'4 or something and
billboard's like hey he's like what are
you doing here he's like i'm i'm doing a
movie about a performer and i want to
watch
that's a little that's me that would
make me uncomfortable
an actor being like i'm studying your
movement
just [ __ ] laugh or don't
i don't know why yeah why i mean i think
it's cool when actors aren't like
typical looking i i like when uh like
we're talking about tilda swinton why
can't we have this guy you know i'm not
saying we can have him i'm just saying
every every girl i talk to is like oh
adam driver he's the sexiest man alive
or whatever i'm like all right
i've seen the face
but i think the face for a ladies like
an actor that you're like that dude's
hot
i hesitate to say just because i'm just
a loyal girlfriend and he i know he's
gonna watch this these are celebrities
though i know i i'm just that's how good
of a person i am wow you're a good
[ __ ] person i know right damn
you won't even give it yeah i respect
that how about like from like the 40s or
50s that way it's not they're dead
they're dead let's go dead men
all right i mean
60. you're like a honkey
you're not you're not too into the uh no
i'm i've dated every couple okay i don't
care at all there's no pattern between
everyone i've been with they all look
different
um i mean he's gay but like rock hudson
is obviously really
what do you mean everybody loved her
i've just never heard that i like it
he's got aids
that was the catch you get the bang rock
hudson but you do get it
i never knew he was a
handsome guy yeah i guess you're right
look at that jaw
look he's got the the manly chin too
i i'm actually rarely attracted to men i
think it's really unfair that women on
the whole are so much more attractive
right
i mean look we're drinking we'll go with
you all day on this one
yeah
i'll say this right now i would much
rather [ __ ] a woman than a man yeah
i don't care who i piss off i think i'm
with you i mean every day on the train
there's like
20 beautiful women just you can just
turn your head and see one but man it's
like never my body's disgusting
i look terrible shirtless
yeah i don't know like the fact that
women can be turned on by like talent
and charm and personality is
that's our only saving grace thank god
thank god but you don't care about that
in women you don't care we care we care
but it doesn't it definitely elevates
them for sure definitely elevates if a
woman is
self-aware smart funny personality when
you're young doesn't matter you're right
when you get older yeah i very much
value a a great personality it's huge
especially if you want to like talk
about dating and you know becoming uh
more of a thing you definitely need all
that i go on some bad first dates
i do i get a lot of like you can use
this in your act i'm like
let me use this instead
right my [ __ ] head off
a little uh kurt cobain
no it's i mean look there's
women look the other way on looks for
sure men we do look the other way on
personality a lot because we value looks
but what i mean
you're less likely to go for a woman
who's like average looking but who has
like felt like very accomplished and
talented like you need the attraction
whereas you need it yeah i think men are
much more shallow and we're yeah we're
just wired that way it's kind of like
biology hey reproduce good offspring
whatever
and then the other stuff will come later
but also how are you supposed to know
the personality immediately you can see
a woman walk by and go holy [ __ ] she's
gorgeous but it's not like you can go
she's funny or smart or whatever because
you gotta have a conversation i just
think a lot of men are
just
we're just shallow i think we're just
often looking for like
oh this is gonna sound crass where we
can dump our next load
whoa wait ah geez well that's
inappropriate
i walked mark
no right right
now
i said are you writing for hallmark
happy valentine's day no i think when
you're in a relationship
like look i very much value a
relationship when i'm in it but i think
a lot of guys that sound terrible i
think a lot of guys are are very much of
shallow and looking
how we are
yeah i do think that like i i it's a
fact if you meet someone great of course
like monogamy one woman
i'm all in but when you're not
when you're seeking them out
i do think there is like a
think about how much more men masturbate
than women
yeah is that wrong i don't know
um that's probably true i'm not the
right person to ask oh really her mom's
listening to
my gal matt here's weird i i you know
for a guy it's like an oil change you
knock it out you're done whatever my gal
will rub one out for like two hours
really yeah but rarely
maybe like once a week or twice a week
but that's how long an adam driver movie
is
yeah exactly
so uh
that's the difference i i'm done in 30
seconds 40 seconds you know
one uh you know
once again arp commercial and i'm done
you know but she's got a she goes she
watches three modern
families do wait so you know and she
loves that o'neill know this uh she'll
she'll tell me i'm like hey where i i
called you earlier she's like i was
rubble one out wow yeah
well we're very open
damn yeah i just i'm not i think once
you're in you're in but i do think
there's like a
a lot of guys on apps are just looking
for sex of course you know and i think a
lot of women on there are like long-term
only no hookups yeah i think that's why
they have to put that out there because
they know that guys are [ __ ] sure i
think that's changing though i think
there's a lot of women who also just
want to hook up but yeah it's like i
don't know maybe weirder to say that out
loud i don't know yeah it shouldn't be i
feel like we've you know we say well
society this and that it's like well
let's change it you know like
i think guys try so little already to
begin with the effort is so minimal on
these dates that like if a woman said
that they'd put in
zero effort
no woman wants a guy to be like come
over that's a good point you know that's
what it is but don't you ever just want
i mean i know you're in a
super hardcore relationship here you
can't even talk about a celebrity you
you're attracted to
but
tony dan's in taxi that's right
he was cute it was cute but
i forgot my point
he said tony's dancing hardcore
relationship uh
wanting to hook up just to hook up yeah
yeah don't you ever just have that
when you were singing when i turned 25
that was the point when i was able to
have a one-night stand before that i
couldn't imagine really having sex with
someone who i wasn't emotionally
attracted to i don't know what happened
when i turned 25 but suddenly
i was able to hook up with a comedian
who uh
was only able to accept a [ __ ] before
it coming and then handed me a clorox
wipe and said i have to go to sleep now
clorox wife
bill cosby everybody
wow
jesus
a clorox wipe he was just like a
goofball i didn't know what he was doing
you know
and you're so cool
i'm gonna try that she's like he's a
character
[ __ ] egregious scumbag i got a
[ __ ] i'm a goofball
he was a really nice guy he just he
warned me that he was out of practice
with women i was like that's fine i'm
horny let's just go yeah and uh he
wasn't lying so i'm out of practice with
women
you call me like lunchables what do we
do
i don't know what we do here you know
you walk on a plane and they hand you
that wipe that's what dina does and this
guy would come over here
all right it's right when you walk in
that's amazing i mean
look
the single stuff is it is interesting it
is wild out there i do i don't envy
women like no what they have to put up
with and what they have to deal with on
first dates and i think the apps kind of
hurt you guys in the uh negotiation
department because before it was just
like i gotta take this girl out i gotta
buy her drinks just to like maybe get a
shot at grabbing a boob and now i feel
like it's tinder has just like
ramped all that up and the woman has no
bargaining chip anymore really
but you tell me you're the you're the
gash
that's my stage name
[Laughter]
but you know
i feel like that
women had a lot more power
before because it was like hey you know
you want to you want to hook up with me
well they mean there's debates about
this yeah like birth control would like
change the game like now you don't have
to find a partner that's like willing to
provide and all this and
i don't know i think we're all monsters
to be honest i agree with that i agree
like i've had some experiences recently
that make me agree with that for sure oh
yeah where i'm just like wow people are
[ __ ] lunatics yeah
on both sides and then alcohol fuels the
lunatic-ness i do feel like i'm the guy
that women are like i'll [ __ ] him just
to show my ex and i'm just like i didn't
need this
i was that guy too and i was like i'll
be that guy and it still bugged me it
bugged me because then occasionally get
the woman who's just like you're like is
everything cool and they're like
and you're like you miss him she's like
yeah i'm like yeah we don't have to have
sex oh
[ __ ]
yeah i had a guy text me once he's like
this is when i first started doing
comedy like 2006. he's like did you [ __ ]
my uh whatever and i was like oh i
didn't know she was your ex and he's
like you piece of [ __ ] i ought to come
fight you and i'm like well first of all
you're done you guys are exes like
you're allowed to [ __ ] someone's ex
and then he's like well she only did it
to get back at me and i was like yeah
whatever [ __ ] and then it's just
stuck with me and then i texted her when
i was drunk and i was like i thought you
liked me and all this and she was like
grow up you [ __ ] and i was like
but i was also like 21. this chick
sounds hot she was so hot grow up you
[ __ ] and i'm glad i got to have sex
with her i was very lucky because she
was way out of my league but i didn't
think that would bother me and it did
wow
yeah the summer months are here time to
stay fueled and hydrated making
hydration a priority helps us feel
healthier in our everyday lives one
stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of water
hydrates you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone liquid iv
products taste great with 10 great
flavors like concord grape lemon lime
tropical punch i love the i love the
punch that's my go-to oh yeah it's
terrific you use liquid iv first thing
in the morning before a workout when you
feel run down after a long night out
which would what we're doing here oh
yeah got to manage that hydration you
know had a few too many bodega cats yeah
that right the single serve packaging
helps keep you hydrated while on the go
i i definitely have used this and i know
you have too i'm a daily at this point
liquid iv contains five essential
vitamins b3 5 6 12 and vitamin c it
contains three time the electric
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks made with premium ingredients
liquid iv is free from gluten dairy and
soy liquid iv uses cellular transport
technology designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream grab
your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquid iv.com and use code drunk at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk at
liquidity.com
fume
is the safe way to quit smoking fumes
100 canadian maple handcrafted inhaler
is made to replace the hand-to-mouth
habit simply insert their
non-addictive flavored cores
uh fume cores come in dozens of flavors
like peppermint lemon berry bliss ooh
yeah the flavors are good they taste
nice i love the little pipe inhaler
thing it's so cool
fun to suck on fun to put in your mouth
there's no smoke no vape but no nicotine
to worry about even if you're not trying
to quit smoking fumes core can help with
relaxation energy and more whether
you're a smoker or an ex-smoker who
still struggles with cravings fume is
the perfect tool for you it's time to
create positive habits and quit
naturally with fume and we're here to
make it easier head to fume dot com
slash drunk use promo code drunk to save
10 off your whole order save money by
eliminating cigarettes and save on your
initial purchase of fume that's 10 off
your entire order at b r e a t h e f u m
dot com slash drunk and use code drunk
see dina do you have any peeves
oh yeah um
so uh
i don't want um outside clothes to be
inside like when i like if i i make my
boyfriend change his clothes if he wants
to get into my bed if he was wearing
clothes that were
worn outside i think that's normal
though no i rebelled against this for a
period i've understood that women
feel this way i i hear this i mean the
jeans that were on the subway in the bed
usually i understand that yeah
interesting i never thought about it
makes sense it does i mean i i
definitely rebelled and i remember i
dated a woman who i mocked for this and
then in retrospect i was kind of like
yeah you're right
yeah what about shoes off shoes have to
be off um i had a i was dating a guy and
we were like in an argument in the
middle of an argument and then we went
back to my room while we were still
arguing and he was about to step in with
his shoes on i was like what are you
doing take your shoes off and he was so
pissed because of the argument that he
stepped in and started stomping on the
floor and like
i wanted to be angry but the comedian me
was like that's really funny and like
you started laughing yeah
that is the thing like if you land a
great joke heated argument it's a great
bomb diffuser yeah it is
wow man
i didn't know you were this much of a
neat freak i'm not really no no i really
i'm really not this is the one thing
that i'm like obsessive about cleaning
with right
interesting it is the bed i understand
like if someone holds their bed like
sacred where you're like don't [ __ ] with
my
the place i sleep i get that yeah i get
it more and more did you have the friend
growing up was like i have to change
into my sleep clothes i was like sleep
clothes i just go with the boxer and the
shirt yeah i never uh yeah i was always
an underwear guy yeah
i have sleep clothes
what are sleep clothes just like a huge
t-shirt
uh-huh yeah that's fine that's that's i
feel like that's the pjs any pj friends
that's [ __ ] weird no i don't have
like designated like matching pj sets my
gal's got it she's got the full button
with the pocket i'm like what are you
wearing like little tucks she had mad
men what the hell i know right like a
smoking jack and a fight look like
snoozy yeah yeah she married to pete
campbell
but it's very strange but it's i think
it's just how you get brought up peeve
oh here's a pee for you
what's going on with this one the hard
to find garbage can i'm at a friend's
house i got a banana peel on my hand and
a beer can and the other one and i'm
like opening drawers
turns out it was like one of those
slide-out garbage cans but it was like
this slim drawer that's under the sink i
would have never i
i couldn't find it
just put the garbage can out
yeah i don't like the weird drawer
garbage cans it pissed me off like you
got to press a button it rolls in right
right
so i'm just holding garbage for 12
minutes like looking around and
everything
oh wait what are you where you at on a
garbage can
i'm trying to think of where my garbage
can is it's out in the open it's next to
the dog food all right you have a dog i
have half a dog it's uh it's my
roommate's dog oh boy he's my best
friend and we went to adopt the dog
together so i consider the dog half mine
right um yeah he's the best i grew up
muslim and we're not allowed to have
dogs is that right yeah why not no
it's an abusive religion i don't know
they don't let you have a dog
yeah it's like pork is considered filthy
and then dogs too and i it's not clear
to me why it's like an arbitrary thing
and i understand like i don't agree with
but i understand why the pork is a no-go
but why i don't get the dough i think it
just
you pick the one thing that you guys
also do
why why eat pork i know i'm just kidding
but but but the dog thing i don't
understand well it's sad because i look
this is a big generalization about
muslims but like i feel like dogs
cleavage
and bacon would really lighten the mood
i didn't even know about the dog thing
dogs like relieve stress can we get a
meeting with mohammed i think i think
mark could really change the vibe
muhammad love what you're doing if we
could just loosen up on the women the
pork
maybe the beard maybe that beard's
ridiculous it's really hot out yes
it's a lot of sand
come on
i don't know why but yeah so it's
life-changing it's life-changing would
you do you think
do you think you maybe you and your guy
move full-time together do you think you
get a dog i can never live without a dog
anymore i just it's so pacifying to just
look at him and say oh yeah the simple
pleasures of life are just like eating
going on a walk like licking your
[ __ ] whatever right it's just like
simple pleasure we're getting it licked
yeah
shingles has this great joke about how
down syndrome kids are like dog because
they're always happy they mean well
they're ingrained it's i'm not gonna do
as big because i don't know if it's out
there yet but it's so true the dog it's
nothing but positive it's rarely you
know sure they'll [ __ ] somewhere every
now and then or puke on the carpet but
it's all an upper it's just one big
valium they're love machines which is
what humans are supposed to be but we
get all screwed up screw it up thanks
twitter
it really does [ __ ] you up yeah yeah you
look at it sometimes i'm in a bad mood
i'm like why didn't batman like i looked
at twitter too much
you have to stop looking at it and it'll
change your life the algorithm will
punish you and you'll never be able to
get a tweet again that has a lot of
likes but it's worth your money it's
worth it trump is happier than any of us
well he's on a new one now i think yeah
there's like eight eight twitter
copies whatever you call those
can we do a couple news stories matt
do we have anything
justin timberlake went viral for the
wrong reasons now he's saying sorry the
singer was caught performing an awkward
dance routine during a performance in
washington dc
and he had a hilarious reply dc i want
to apologize to you for two reasons here
and here he said on instagram stories
zooming to a close-up of his feet i had
a long talk with both of them
individually and said don't you ever do
that to me again
why don't you do the same thing to his
dick on instagram stories
well we got i don't get the dancing i
don't understand what did he do
that's why isn't that his job there he
is he's bringing sexy back
oh he did a [ __ ] walk
is that appropriation or some [ __ ]
[Music]
he's not good he has to apologize for
dan it's his job isn't it
oh man this is getting out of control
what are we doing i don't know lizzo
apologized for saying spazz really you
can't say spazz no that was in a rap
song it's like they talk about murdering
people i don't think dancing's that bad
honestly i'm a terrible dancer but i
mean i don't [ __ ] oh i would kill to
be able to do this
i'd cut a woman's hands off to be able
to dance like that
but
what do you think good looking guy
i know really interesting jessica biel
oh i think she's unbelievable she's
crazy unreal box office poison though is
she she can't make a good movie to save
her life that show she was in is a hit
though people like that show's a hit
all right well good to have her back but
i'm talking movies
movies are dead anyway
yeah nobody saw top gun well top gun and
thor and then what else unless it's like
a [ __ ] summer blockbuster no one's
going to the theater man
i know it's sad
because i'm sure you had a great time at
the beacon with with full room
full room laugh from a movie
i was in between phil hanley and dan
soder were watching joel this movie and
i'm like this is special man it's like a
buddy
it's a special night but uh
yeah who gives a [ __ ] about this [ __ ] i
mean come on yeah what else beyond
disturbing anti-assault billboard sparks
controversy after resurfacing this isn't
i've never heard of inverness florida
but it's in florida
uh getting drunk is never an excuse
she's your daughter not your date
we're calling incest out
refuge house.com i mean first off
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] we need a
billboard to tell you the incest is bad
yeah i don't need alcohol to molest my
daughter thank you very much yeah she's
just florida she's hot sober this
reminds me of the end of chinatown where
the dad is explaining like how he could
have raped his daughter and he was just
like at the right time in your life you
could do
anything just gloss right past it right
john houston legend best picture
incredible
one of one of the best movies of all
time this is wild who paid somebody paid
for this
the anti-insect i i'm telling you mark
my words 50 years incest will be
accepted
i'm telling you because it's love
we'll be in our 80s and we're just like
i don't get these kids yeah i'm telling
you i don't get them
you wait and see
in 50 years we'll reconnect
and we'll all be [ __ ] our cousins
jeez
i mean what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people yeah well we got too much time on
our hands and everybody's got a voice
that's going gonna make you feel bad
about where you live if you're driving
by and you see that billboard
they don't have that [ __ ] in manhattan
oh we haven't needed it yet
florida baby we have the options yeah
you're on some of these [ __ ] everness
uh tinders you you run out real quick
you're like i guess i'm going to my
family
right
yeah
but her personality was great
damn what else we got 6 000 bees removed
from inside a wall of omaha couples home
about six thousand bees were recently
removed oh it's the same thing twice
a hundred year old home thomas and mary
lou gottier
told the omaha world herald they have
been planting bee friendly flowers
inside or outside their midtown home but
they never expected the bees to move in
that's insane this is good though
because aren't we like low on bees
this is great the bees are they keep the
world going round they're putting bee
friendly flowers it's like if you
decorated your home for halloween and
then got annoyed when kids showed up
right
right
you set this [ __ ] up you put candy
outside in a plastic pumpkin
it's you know look i'm in new york if i
lived on a ground floor i would not put
cheese outside
yeah you know like you got to be aware
of what is out there
oh my god i've never been i'm going
there in a couple months
or so hey well you might get some honey
because uh this is there's got to be
some good to this there's got to be a
good spin they get honey in the
apartment or
no you just get dead [ __ ] bees are
they dead
oh they're dead
gross dead bees oh i'm picturing buzzing
healthy bees oh that's [ __ ] gross i'm
drunk
[ __ ] sauce i'm still thinking about
the incest thing can we go back to that
let's go back to the princess yeah what
do you think of a bit
oh here we go
it's really hard to find someone you
relate to
oh that's right there we go write it
down
good drunk brain you know what else
that's the writer
the other writer right there folks matt
clifford hire her we got a whole incest
chunk you can clip up for this one
but this is what it's like in the
writer's room they move past something
and i'm like i need more time and then
i'm like can we go back to like an hour
ago and we're talking about that other
thing i have a good joke now we think a
gaffigan's bit when you see a movie too
late
i don't want to talk about heat now yeah
this wine is going down like [ __ ]
sugar right now dude i'm sorry booger
sugar but uh i will say a good a good
joke's a good joke it shouldn't matter
if it took you an extra hour
but also another perk of uh incest
you've already met the parents
[Laughter]
there we go now we got a joke
uk tribunal
rules calling a bald man is sexual so
let me do that again i've been drinking
too uk tribunal rules calling a man bald
to sexual harassment
uh the tribunal whose members alluded to
their own experience with hair loss also
compared calling a man bald to
commenting on the sides of a woman's
breasts interesting this is absurd
interesting well a man bald is never
sexual you're calling a woman's breasts
out that's sexual what if you're
attracted to bald men
okay fine if you're saying [ __ ] me you
bald [ __ ]
in that case it is uh sexual but i think
for the most part breast versus bald is
not an equal sure they use the wrong
term it's body shaming if anything
yes good call body shaming exactly yeah
sexual harassment exactly no one unless
you have a bald fetish which is
different yeah wow well we pick and
choose with the body shaming you know we
go hey chris christie's a fat [ __ ] huh
and then we all go yeah but then we go
lena dunham's a fat [ __ ] yeah people go
hey
and you're like
well which one is it
this is a bit i'm trying to work on oh
really body shaming
i was i remember in my first body
shaming incident i went to the dentist
and he said i have a clinically small
mouth
is that this huh
but it sounds pornographic right like it
sounds like
too small for what right you know it
would look big next to that mouth yadda
yadda he said he wanted to install a
widening tool
oh that's filthy it sounds like that
sounds like cool dirty talk yeah it does
what widening tool like the thing that
like pushes it out yeah that like put
it's like a retainer sort of but like
permanent and then it like do you have a
small mouth i don't i do really trust me
joe list is a change
i'm a fast eater
anyway out of your mouth looks perfectly
normal thank you
could use a widening tool
yeah
joe list has a type 2 mouth so his
doctor said the same thing
he's a small mouth yeah
he said your mouth is like abnormally
small and
we can't get certain tools in there
damn
yeah all right he was a dentist but
either way it's called a type 2 mouth
teacher turned only fan star pregnant by
student is keeping the baby zoom in on
what the caption says what does the
caption say
teacher turn only fan star oh yeah she's
a attractive teacher if this is out of
florida i'll uh
i'll finish that bottle of wine really
no
that's actually a horrible book on that
yeah that's not a good i don't know you
didn't do yourself i did it backwards if
this is not in florida i might have it
on my phone i'll leave my head sent me
this i mean i can read it
a lot of teachers [ __ ] their students
nowadays a lot of female teachers well
that's the ones that report on the hot
ones is that what it is i think so yeah
all right this lady's a kook
and ah by the way kids they don't know
how good they got it because we all had
a hot teacher growing up and back then
you could pay 4.99 and see her naked
your teacher i mean come on you're crazy
oh that happened in high school there
you go lady yeah she was history teacher
she had implants and then she got fired
for hooking up with a student
wow fascinating
i guess i don't know oh here we go
yeah here it is anonymous she wrote it's
crazy that i'm having a baby
with a former student but the same thing
could happen in any profession
that's not true by the way
teachers and professors
right you can't have a baby with a
student in any profession in her defense
it's a former student and he was 22.
so that kind of makes it okay
yeah that's actually they didn't say
that
she was he was 22. that's the story she
met when they were when he was 16 but
then how about uh president macron from
france he's he's married to his t-shirt
what's how is that any different um
33 year old it's crazy is it because
she's very uh she's very uh urbane is
that why it's different i mean what's
what's the difference here i mean
she seems like it's more sophisticated
maybe but he's in so it was totally
illegal he was an adult when they had
sex i think so oh
but the problem is that they met when he
was 16. so she's in trouble i mean and
she's an only fan so it's it's a good
headline this [ __ ] would never happen in
france that's all i'm saying he's
married to his teacher she's like 30
years older than him oh wow yeah is that
right 25 maybe
do you remember when it was like normal
to count down to when like the olsen
twins would be legal we were just
talking about that last week that was a
sign in new orleans like counting down
two months to go oh my god that was a
big joke
i guess technically they're they're
keeping it legal
but yeah i mean it's gross but it's also
like
at the same time
it's straight it's a strange move but
that was like people were high five and
look at that they're taking photos with
it it was like a big deal it is also
weird that the ultimate fantasy i mean i
know it's taboo but it's like
isn't that the ultimate like porn search
like my hot teacher
of course i mean that's like we all
fantasized about it like it's a rock
song any guy who claims he didn't jack
off to a teacher of his is full of [ __ ]
oh yeah we all did it yeah
i had a gym teacher who was he was a hot
guy
right up to him
but we all did it oh yeah of course i
mean that's a it's a adult woman
in the room who knows your name yeah
it's you have to do it it's like your
friend's mom we all jerked off to a
friend's mom yeah or dad
there you go he was the dad that you
found attracted me
never
no was it the religion that
yeah well first of all i didn't know how
to masturbate until i was like 22.
really that would not have changed yeah
weird i cracked that code very early
i was like i got this i got this down oh
totally yeah an expert by you know
12
[Laughter]
that's nice and then you have friends
like you ever do that they're like oh my
god now now we're off and running the
first time i had a wet dream i thought
it was like i was i thought someone
played a prank on me i was like maple
syrup what the [ __ ]
wow that's some dark jews you got there
yeah
the texture oh i see i see yeah i
thought i wet the bed yeah for sure but
there was never dads that you were like
that dad is attracted you didn't even
feel that side of you well i mean there
were there were people i was attracted
to like i had a there was a
my home room teacher everyone had a
crush on him and he was great one time
we went to the mall and saw him with his
girlfriend we were like ah
as though we were she had worked with
him
yes for sure yeah
um so yeah no of course i had those
feelings but like i didn't know what to
physically do with them sure confusing
interesting i also never had uh a door
for a long time oh
like
so we had an apartment that um only had
one bedroom so my brother got to take it
because
um and so i had like a sectioned off
part of the living room that was my room
so i never could have like done anything
like that
got it
maybe in the bathroom
um
i guess
i guess i didn't it still just wasn't a
thing on my mind yeah yeah you were you
were oppressed and yeah it was the
religious element for sure yeah my my
gayle said she didn't see her vagina
till she was like 21. why
you just i mean they're hard to see yeah
they're they're you know downward facing
dog there she didn't want to
like what are you gonna do step on a
mirror i guess you gotta you gotta go
out of your way to see your clan you
know
so it wasn't a bug self-help book you
gotta go out of your way to see a clam
it's available at barnes and noble today
i mean it was until i pulled out the old
super eight that uh you know she saw
that thing but yeah i mean
i think a lot of ladies and look
speaking out of school here but i think
they're this is this is a weird area you
know even like tampons she was like that
was the first time i
i'd done stuff with it yes another thing
in islam you're not supposed to use
tampons whoa wow nothing's gonna go in
there except for the dick of the guy
you're married to whoo
what about so what do you go maxie
yes who was pads damn
wings or no wings
i've seen one maxi pad commercial
that's crazy yeah and does your mom
abide by all this
i haven't asked her
yeah bring her in
jerry jerry [ __ ] you don't know me all
right that's tough yeah that's i mean
that sounds damn being a muslim woman
does not sound easy
that's why i'm
here yeah we got to make this cartoon
yeah muslim lady the first episode tampa
[Laughter]
damn dana wait is that all the news
okay is that it all right cool all right
well hey you got any uh dates do you
want to plug um
i'll be in wisconsin from
the
uh august 17th through the 20th it's
just random places in wisconsin
dme if anyone's over there and wants to
know yeah hit the website oh yeah go to
or your tickets on the side
no oh my god i haven't updated this
this is a nightmare i have not updated
this look at that tiny mouth what the
[ __ ] is that small mouth
yeah there's nothing on that website uh
make sure to follow dean on all social
media media platforms deena hashem uh
twitter instagram yes great writer great
jokes
good stuff
thank you
funny comic and uh where are you gonna
be there sloppy jalopy should we do bits
before we go oh geez sorry i'll plug
some dates i mean i got a lot coming up
but let's should we do bits first hell
yeah any bits let me see if i have
anything worthwhile
i mean i got i got a few minutes oh then
i got a mine on my phone here
all right what do you got one uh there
dee
me yeah yeah i have a line that i just
tried and it bombed so horribly that i'm
not sure
i'm just trying to build on my abortion
chunk and
i have this line where it's like you you
really feel old when you tell a doctor
that you're pregnant and they assume
that you want to keep it
is that something i don't know that's
funny yeah
uh i think it it's uh the crowd might
not have it's
i think it needs more of a connection
like a clearer leap
i feel like they're like what do you
mean if you say it's bombing i don't
know yeah i if you have if you tell the
doctor i'm pregnant and they assume you
want to keep it
yeah you're basically being like no i
don't
i don't want this it's like it's a it's
like a thing like i'm just a little girl
i can't be i mean look at me right
yeah this little mouth i can't even feed
myself
it's like the opposite of you know how
women will get carded and be like oh i'm
so complimented it's the opposite of
that like oh [ __ ] yeah i'm pregnant now
i gotta keep it
that is that is like almost like a new
york thing i feel like too like any
other part of the country they're like
yeah i'm keeping them right it's like a
coastal elite thing where we're like
yeah we're not we're not i still got a
lot of me to take care of
i still have dreams yeah
i still have dreams you're saying you
don't want to keep it
i went to the doctor to be like we got
to get rid of this i thought it was
implies sorry okay i [ __ ] maybe it
needs more context i get it now i get it
that's fine no i think i'm just a little
girl it's funny yes
[Music]
i don't know i had a similar not it's
the joke's not similar but it's a joke i
couldn't really crack in my last hour
and now i'm kind of tweaking it for the
next set but it was about like
i slept with someone who was very
different from me we obviously couldn't
have a kid together but you know i made
the mistake and
you know
plan b we took care of it but then she
text me like we should hang out again
she texts me two and a half weeks later
got my period i write back love it you
know i was excited yeah she said uh
we should do it again i said i can't
just get you a plan b every time we hook
up that's you know she's very different
from me
very different beliefs and she said well
um
yeah well i mean we can't do that and i
said well if we got to that point i've
never paid for this but we would have to
get an abortion obviously and she goes i
would never do that
i was like wow you ever think your full
woman's right to choose and then it just
it turns out you're pro-abortion
like i thought i was a feminist it turns
out i'm a monster right right so i think
my angle is like i'm pro my life yeah
that's good it's a good line
it hits sometimes sometimes it's like
yeah
it's such a touchy sub yeah it's not
because of the joke it's just because
people freeze up yeah i feel like
structurally it works but it's one of
those where i'm like oh we don't like
you right now right it's like one of
those things you have to earn it and i
think i have to preface where i'm like
i'm not saying you should get abortions
willy-nilly i'm saying this is for like
special occasions right
yeah yeah
yeah and maybe maybe the end
of the bit could be something like she
had a miscarriage and we were both
satisfied
you know because no one had to get an
abortion but you still have the baby i
don't know it's like a nice uh
middle ground that everybody wins
i mean it's not i guess she doesn't win
but uh
you don't have the kid
a miscarriage everybody wins
except the kid
what do you got but i'm saying it's it's
not you didn't get an abortion but you
also don't have a kid so it's kind of a
nice there's something compromised i
think you made me think of an abortion
joke so what we're doing mark are you
gonna keep the abortion trend rolling i
had a dumb idea this won't work but i'll
throw it out there just to stay on
target here on topic but
i looked into adoption because you know
you hear all these kids out there with
the
with nothing going on nobody wants to
help them
it's a shame though we buy everything
online now everything's all over the
place you can read all these reviews but
you can't review a kid
wouldn't that be nice if you could have
a review on this kid
but then i realized nobody would buy the
or nobody would adopt the the [ __ ] up
one like i hung out with a little
twitchy one star
you know
i don't know if there's anything there
but it's definitely bombing
i do like that idea i mean i just want
it to be real
so i don't i don't know well you know
you buy a [ __ ] mug and there's 18
reviews like ah the mug it's it's too
heavy it doesn't work whatever but kids
the biggest
adoption of your life
you can't this is an 18-year commitment
right can you tell me if he's going to
bite me for no reason exactly what
return policy no return
that's something
so yeah that that's the idea no reviews
on an adoption here's a twist we need
amazon to get into the adoption game
there we go
that might be the bridge it needs a
thing i like that
amazon got on board mike [ __ ] on amazon
all you want they would they would get
tight on the adoption game yes they
would overnight delivery
[Laughter]
how come this kid's so good looking i
got prime
[Laughter]
i got a kid and a subscription to watch
bosh
pretty cool
you love bosch
it's a good show it is good it's good
it's a dad show so i feel i feel like i
i didn't get your bit now i get it and i
[ __ ] it up we all just do kid bits i
love it there's like a theme here kid
bits is the name of the uh the epstein
duck
i think we got about nine epstein jokes
in this this episode so that's all over
i'm gonna be on the road i'm where i'm
gonna be uh yeah uh [ __ ]
uh
san jose
la
pittsburgh dania beach louisville irvine
omaha phoenix lexington new brunswick
okc all over this [ __ ] so springfield
see you on the road hell yeah same here
uh comedy connections and providence san
antonio lexington houston
you name it uh portland maine portland
oregon seattle toronto vancouver
uh new orleans philly boston so come on
out say hello check out dina's stuff
we'll see on the road get on the patreon
buy a mug get a shirt we might be
drunkpod.com the merch is outstanding
bodega cat yeah it's like it's either
out or it's almost out so you know if
it's already out you know but if it's
almost out it's like this [ __ ] close
yeah and it's the best whiskey you're
ever gonna try so i can't wait for you
to try it have an abortion adopt a kid
and
save a muslim we love you all right
thank you dina and follow dina make sure
to follow dina she's a great guy oh yeah
[Music]
and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we
might be
true
[Music]